you
in his critically acclaimed rise of the
two long cloth sets off on a race
against a ruthless organization known as
Trinity to find the secret of
immortality in the mountains of Siberia
throughout her expedition she must
conquer a world protecting its secrets
endure perilous conditions with unstable
landscapes use guerrilla combat tactics
to survive and explore all inspiring
deadly tunes whose ancient spaces are
filled with deadly traps and
environmental puzzles
Lara's epic journey becomes even more
immersive on the PC version of rise of
the Tomb Raider as Crystal Dynamics and
Nick sees introduced several new
technical features to the game that push
the boundaries of next-gen visuals
welcome to the PC tech feature for rise
of the Tomb Raider
by partnering with Nvidia rise of the
Tomb Raider is able to offer a very
high-end ambient occlusion technique
called H Bao Plus which reduces
artifacts and produces a richer and more
detailed ambient lighting when compared
to previous techniques H Bao plus is a
faster more efficient and significantly
more effective rendering technique the
PC hardware allows rise of the Tomb
Raider to use anisotropic filtering
across all surfaces so when viewed from
an angle the quality of the textures in
the distance is greatly enriched
hardware tessellation greatly enhances
the detail of uneven surfaces in the
ground rocks and bricks silhouettes and
surface features are geometrically
represented when viewed up close
making the surfaces feel even more
tangible and realistic with the
increased geometry processing power
available on PCs we are able to enhance
the geometry and objects like buildings
so that they are significantly more
visible even when viewed at a distance
as a result hub spaces feel even larger
now and aid the players exploration the
beautiful yet hostile environments come
to life as previously static foliage now
reacts dynamically to Lara's movements
as well as weather effects
thank you for watching the rise of the
Tomb Raider PC tech feature Crystal
Dynamics and nixies worked tirelessly to
push the PC version to new heights
giving players unprecedented visual
fidelity and the most realistic looking
Tomb Raider adventure to date pre-order
the digital deluxe version for the
ultimate experience